die eu-kommission hat die überprüfung
der sommerzeit gestartet jetzt haben
bürger aus der ganzen eu die gelegenheit
die sommerzeit zu beurteilen und
gegebenenfalls abzulehnen
wir hatten ja schon über die
sinnlosigkeit und die verrückten
umstände berichtet die zur einführung
geführt hatten heute übrigens klicks um
science-fiction aus dem bett mir geht es
nur so semi also herzlich willkommen
hier du wir zusammen können etwas ändern
gerade haben wir es ja bei der
neuregelung des urheberrechts in der eu
gezeigt und ihr hier bei pixum habt mit
eurem protest demonstriert dass er nicht
alles mit euch machen lasst die upload
filter sind jetzt erstmal vom tisch und
wenn das gesetz dann im september neu
beraten wird dann dürfte es erhebliche
veränderungen geben vielen dank dafür an
euch ihr seid mit dafür verantwortlich
und jetzt geht es um die sommerzeit und
die könnt ihr auch abschaffen
die sommerzeit ist nämlich sinnlos das
erste mal wurde sie ja von deutschland
und österreich-ungarn während des ersten
weltkrieges eingeführt weil man sich da
durch energieeinsparung versprach mit
der eingesparten energie
damals wurden städte noch mit gas
beleuchtet strom mit kohle hergestellt
wollte man diese rohstoffe für das
militär einsparen doch dass man durch
das ausnutzen der hellen morgenstunden
mehr energie einspart ist mehr als
umstritten im gegenteil alle bekannten
untersuchungen kommen zu dem ergebnis
dass der minderverbrauch zu
vernachlässigen ist das ergebnis war
meistens das zwar weniger künstliche
beleuchtung benötigt wird aber mehr
geheizt wird 2005 fasste die
bundesregierung diese erkenntnisse noch
mal in einer antwort auf eine kleine
anfrage der fdp fraktion zusammen und
heute dürften die auswirkungen sogar
umgekehrt seien dadurch dass die
beleuchtung deutlich weniger energie
verbraucht als noch vor zehn jahren
dürfte der effekt inzwischen umgekehrt
sein
wir dürften also durch das verstärkte
heizen mehr energie verbrauchen aber
darüber gibt es keinerlei erkenntnisse
oh mann doch die energieeinsparungen
sind heute gar nicht mal mehr der grund
für die einführung der sommerzeit jetzt
kommt mit das verrückte der eigentliche
grund ist die harmonisierung derzeit in
europa um den handel zu erleichtern
so steht es explizit in der
stellungnahme der bundesregierung
als sophie bitte noch mal ganz langsam
die sommerzeit gibt es weil sie andere
mal eingeführt haben vollkommen ohne
grund und wir uns jetzt in europa nach
diesen ländern richten obwohl es gar
keinen sinn macht
ja und dabei sind die gesundheitlichen
folgen noch nicht berücksichtigt viele
menschen beklagen schlafstörungen
schlappheit und eine schwedische studie
kommt sogar zu dem ergebnis dass in den
tagen nach der zeitumstellung mehr
menschen einen herzinfarkt erleiden und
genau deshalb macht die eu-kommission
jetzt dazu eine umfrage
hierbei whatsapp habe ich euch ja dazu
befragt und das ergebnis war eindeutig
von 4234 befragten stimmten 78,9 prozent
dagegen
eine überwältigende mehrheit er sieht
also schlecht aus für die sommerzeit und
das ist auch gut so in der befragung
können die bürger zudem entscheiden ob
sie eine ständige winter oder eine
ständige sommerzeit wollen ihr könnt
jetzt also wieder die politik
mitbestimmen legt los der link zur
befragung ist in der video beschreibung
oder er bekommt ihn per whatsapp womit
wir beim thema wären wenn ihr keine
videos dazu und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann endet nicht bei
whatsapp darum geht ihr die kaputte abo
box hier auf youtube und verpasst kein
video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auf meinen
schwester cara klicks um social media
abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt da ist auch der
link hier und nicht die glocke vergessen
natürlich moment nicht die blogger
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
auch irgendwo da wird die sommerzeit
abgeschafft also drauf klicken wenn er
sehen wollt bis dann bleibt kann